es gibt einen Hilferuf auf hoher See die
Propellermaschine der Hilfsorganisation
sea-watch startet vom kleinen Flughafen
Lampedusa
seit Jahren dokumentiert die Crew der
seabor 2 die Migration übers Mittelmeer
die Passage von der nordafrikanischen
Küste nach Europa ist eine der
tödlichsten Fluchtrouten der Welt
fast täglich machen sich in diesem
Frühjahr Bote auf den Weg Italien
verzeichnet bereits viermal so viele
Ankünfte wie im Vorjahreszeitraum und
hat deshalb den Notstand ausrufen
der Notstand gilt landesweit wir müssen
den Regionen helfen denn das System
steht vor dem Kollaps
hoffentlich versteht Europa dass wir
nicht mehr viel Zeit haben
ich will mir selbst ein Bild von der
Lage auf Lampedusa machen als ich auf
der italienischen Insel Lande die näher
an Afrika als an Europa liegt im Hafen
kommen jetzt fast täglich Menschen an
nachdem sie die gefährliche Passage
übers Mittelmeer geschafft haben sie
werden sofort ins Camp in der Insel
Mitte gebracht
ich bin verabredet mit dr Francesco Daka
der Gynäkologe gehört zur medizinischen
erstversorgungsteam der Insel und
behandelt vor allem die MigrantInnen die
junge Patientin die anonym bleiben will
klagt über Unterleibsbeschwerden oftmals
verbergen sich dahinter traumatische
Erfahrungen
[Musik]
von Gewalt von Traumata in Verbindung
mit körperlicher Gewalt auch sexuelle
Gewalt gegen junge Frauen das sind die
Schicksale die die MigrantInnen mit sich
tragen
wegen der vielen Ankünfte hat er einen
notmannschaft zusammengestellt zwei
Ärzte ein Mediator eine Krankenschwester
und ein Team mit Rettungswagen doch so
groß ihr Wille auch ist eine größere
Anzahl bedürftiger könnten sie kaum
versorgen
die Warnungen die uns vorliegen
verheißen nichts Gutes ich hoffe dass
die Befürchtungen nicht zutreffen dass
eine große Anzahl von Migrantinnen und
Migranten die auf bis zu 400.000
geschätzt wird bereit ist von Tunesien
aus zu starten
muss im Team von Dr darker als
Dolmetscher und Mediator im Einsatz er
wagte selbst vor sechs Jahren die
gefährliche Überfahrt von Libyen aus das
Boot Gerät in Seenot er wurde gerettet
und nach Sizilien gebracht die Frauen
und Kinder sagt er haben am meisten
gelitten
überlebt hat wie wir der versteht
vielleicht nicht was es bedeutet wenn
man nach der Ankunft auf Ärzte trifft
und internationale Organisationen die
helfen Menschen die zuhören das tut
einfach gut
das Aufnahme Camp auf Lampedusa ist mit
der Situation überfordert denn es ist
eigentlich nur für 400 Personen
ausgelegt an manchen Tagen waren es
jetzt bis zu 3.000 innerhalb dürfen wir
nicht drehen das Camp ist strengen
bewacht und von Meter hohen Zäunen
umgeben
diese Aufnahmen zeigen die beengten
Zustände die regelmäßig dann auftreten
wenn neue Boote sehr viele Menschen auf
einmal bringen nicht einmal getrennte
Sanitäreinrichtungen für Frauen und
Männer gibt es
der Notstand soll nun Finanzmittel
schneller auf den Weg bringen für die
rechtsgerichtete Regierung von
Ministerpräsidentin Meloni ist die
illegale Migration ein Prüfstein hatte
sie doch den WLAN eine deutlich härtere
Gangart in der Migrationspolitik
angekündigt stattdessen kommen mehr
Migranten als zuvor deshalb verschärft
die Regierung jetzt das
Einwanderungsrecht und polarisiertem
eigenen Land wie auf dieser Demo im
Zentrum Roms findet die politische Linke
nicht Italien seine Not sondern die
Migranten
Elli Schleim ist frisch gewählte Chefin
der sozialdemokratischen Partie der
demokratico die 37-Jährige sieht
Italiens Integrationsarbeit gefährdet
was wir jetzt sehen ist noch schlimmer
als salvinis Sicherheit
es war schwer vorstellbar aber sie tun
es sie machen es stellt das
warum sage ich das weil sie das
italienische System der dezentralen
Unterbringung abbauen und stattdessen
die Ansammlung der Asylsuchenden in
größeren Lagern anstreben wo dann
Menschenrechte missachtet werden so wird
jegliche Möglichkeit von Integration zu
nicht gemacht die Inklusion um
Handlungsfähigkeit unter Beweis zu
stellen hat die italienische Regierung
jetzt einen Sonderkommissar für
Migration eingesetzt und nach lampidosa
geschickt
ist es die bisherige Praxis im Hotspot
auf Lampedusa zu verändern
sowohl das zuständige Ministerium als
auch der Kommissar wollen die Migranten
schneller aufs Festland bringen
die Menschen werden mit der Fähre von
der Insel gebracht um den Hotspot zu
entlasten auch die junge Frau die bei dr
darker in Behandlung war kommt zur
weiteren medizinischen Versorgung mit
aufs Festland für sie ein Schritt voller
Hoffnung
während meines Besuchs sie auf Lampedusa
fällt mir das deutsche Rettungsschiff
Luis Michelle auf unterstützt vom Street
Art Künstler Banksy die Mannschaft hat
die härtere Gangart der italienischen
Regierung deutlich zu spüren bekommen
ein neues Dekret erschwert ihre Einsätze
erzählt mir Jana alt denn nach nur einer
Rettungsaktion werde den Schiffen einen
oft weit entfernter Hafen zugewiesen
weil sie aber zwei Rettungsaktion
durchgeführt haben wurde ihr Schiff hier
festgesetzt das ist natürlich mega
tragisches dass wir für 20 Tage von
unserer Arbeit abgehalten werden wir
sehen es kommen gerade mega viele Leute
in Europa an ähm genau und unsere Hilfe
dringend benötigt weil das Sekret ihre
Ansicht nach nicht im Einklang mit
internationalem Seerecht steht haben
Hilfsorganisationen jetzt klar gegen die
italienische Regierung eingereicht
private Seenot wo sollen nicht
kriminalisiert werden
es braucht ein klares Bekenntnis der
Seenotrettung es braucht ein klares
Bekenntnis dazu das Zusammenarbeit
zwischen senutrettungsleitstellen der
Küstenwache und zivilen
seenotrettungsorganisationen
vorangebracht wird
außerdem fordern sie dringend eine neue
europäische Rettungsmission die Crew der
seber 2 registriert allein in den
vergangenen Tagen so viele Boote wie
lange nicht und Lumpi Dusa meldet an nur
einem Tag 869 Neuankömmlinge und
mindestens zwei Menschen die die
gefährliche Route übers Mittelmeer nicht
überlebt haben